mais chez un ami quel bonheur oui quel
bonheur quelle joie quelle émotion de
nous retrouver ce soir en famille dans
cette belle famille des républicains
tout simplement ça fait du bien ça fait
du bien de vous voir si nombreux réunis
rassemblés ici au cannet merci à michèle
tabarot pour son accueil chez elle
merci à notre premier vice président
jean leonetti qui incarne cette vision
du rassemblement dans la diversité de
notre famille politique
je suis heureux ce soir heureux et fiers
de vous accueillir dans les alpes
maritimes
en tant que président de la première
fédération des républicains de france
oui mes habits grâce à vous grâce à ses
onze mille militants du littoral de la
montagne de l'ouest de l'est du
département
mon cher henri mon cher jean claude qui
forment cette grande famille
vous êtes là vous êtes là et du fond du
coeur je veux vous en remercier merci au
président du département
mon ami charles ange ginésy qui préside
aujourd'hui cette grande collectivité
cette grande et belle collectivités dont
la gestion exemplaire que nous avons
conduite ensemble depuis dix ans charles
ange a permis depuis 2009 la baisse des
dépenses publiques
la baisse du nombre de fonctionnaires la
baisse de la dette et des doors la
baisse des impôts c'est d'un exemple à
suivre
merci du fond du coeur à nos candidats
xavier et puis bernard asso merci
bernard tu incarnes pour nous
l'espérance d'avoir enfin dans les
alpes-maritimes
un député européen et tu seras député
européen le 26 mai prochain
mes chers amis mes chers amis votre
présence si nombreuse dans cette belle
salle de la palestre symbolise le vent
porteur qui souffle sur notre famille
depuis quelques semaines
depuis deux ans mes amis le chemin que
nous avons parcouru est d'autant plus
extraordinaire qu'il a été périlleux et
escarpée mes amis vous n'avez jamais
douté
vous vous n'avez jamais douté vous
n'avez jamais céder au mirage macro nist
et à la farce du nouveau monde
vous êtes
vous êtes militant des républicains mais
bien au delà
vous êtes surtout les militants de la
france de cette france que nous aimons
par dessus tout mais si nous avons
surmonté ces épreuves
c'est aussi et surtout grâce à notre
président grâce à laurent wauquiez
merci laurent merci laurent
je ne voulais pas que je te remercie
mais je vais le faire quand même
c'est mon côté rebelle depuis son
élection
tu a reconstruit notre famille pierre
après pierre tu as démontré que la
droite ne devait plus baisser la tête ni
se soumettre au politiquement correct
alors oui si la droite est de retour
après tant d'épreuves
c'est à toi qu'on le doit
laurent dès le lendemain de ces
européennes de dévots de nouveaux défis
nous attendent à toi d'ouvrir la voie
l'avenir tu appelles j'en suis
profondément convaincu et je veux te
dire que je serai derrière toi de toutes
mes forces pour préparer cet avenir
en choisissant françois-xavier bel ami
tu as déjà démontré la capacité à offrir
une colonne vertébrale idéologique à la
droite ce choix courageux et audacieux
c'est le tien oui mes amis
françois-xavier bellamy et de droite
certains s'en sont étonnés
d'autres nous l'ont reproché
extraordinairement étonnant que dans un
parti qui s'affirme de droite
républicaine notre candidat soit de
droite ça choque est néanmoins certain
eh bien oui oui
françois xavier et de droite ont la
caricature et on l'a attaqué c'est le
meilleur des symboles et c'est le
meilleur des signes pour l'avenir merci
françois xavier pour ce dynamisme que tu
insuffle à cette belle campagne
alors que le nouveau monde s'offre dans
le conte sombre dans le grotesque
en choisissant une candidate qui
prétendait éradiquer l'extrême droite
alors qu'elle en était originaire tu es
incarna la fidélité la fidélité à des
valeurs à des idées à une nation à une
civilisation
alors oui avec toi
et derrière laurent nous allons gagner
aux français aux français qui hésitent
qui doutent encore et il y en a à ceux
qui restent arrimés au titanic macro
nist
je vous demande de leur poser deux
questions très simples
deux questions quel est le bilan de
monsieur macron depuis deux ans première
question qui peut demain incarner une
alternative crédible et responsable
après ce naufrage le bilan mes amis nous
le subissons vous le connaissez des
paroles des débats sans fin des images
des slogans des comités des commissions
des mets accule pas encore aujourd'hui
notre brillant ministre de l'intérieur
qui indique ne pas avoir maîtrisé sa
parole ne pas avoir bien apprécié la
situation
oui il a menti ou il ne connaissait pas
la réalité des faits dans les deux cas
c'est extrêmement grave pour quelqu'un
qui est supposé protéger les français
bref nous sommes face à une grande
illusion
où sont les actes où sont les résultats
macro aujourd'hui c'est plus de déficits
c'est plus de dette
un niveau record de chômage en europe
une croissance parmi les plus faibles
marqueront aujourd'hui c'est plus
d'immigration 262000 titre de séjour
accordés en 2018
un record dans l'histoire de france 122
mille demandeurs d'asile 22 % de plus
qu'en 2010 est là encore un record dans
l'histoire de france
si ces chiffres continuent au même
rythme et bien nous accueillerons dans
ce quinquennat macron deux millions et
demi d'étrangers supplémentaires en
situation régulière sans parler de ceux
qui sont arrivés en situation illégale
c'est totalement suicidaire macro mes
amis c'est aussi plus d'impôts je ne
sais pas s'il y a des retraités dans
cette salle
vous me paraissez tous animés par cette
jeunesse de l' enthousiasme mais si
jamais il y avait un retraité il saurait
mieux que quiconque combien son pouvoir
d'achat a été sévèrement écornée a été
durement touchée de retraités sur trois
depuis 2010 est revu leur pouvoir
d'achat a reculé
c'est indigne c'est injuste à l'égard de
ceux auxquels nous devons une légitime
reconnaissance à l'égard de ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie pour la nation
à l'égard de ceux qui nous ont transmis
des repères des valeurs un héritage plus
d'impôts si pour les automobilistes
avec cette augmentation des taxes qui
elle n'a pas été effacée et à nouveau
depuis quelques jours le prix des
carburants franchi des records
une augmentation d'impôts pour les
propriétaires et notamment ceux qui ont
subi
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière et
puis au final une augmentation pour tous
les français puisque si nous avons gagné
la coupe du monde de football en 2018
et bien malheureusement nous avons
remporté un autre championnat
celui-là bien moins glorieux puisque
nous sommes devenus le champion du monde
des impôts et des taxes
[Applaudissements]
mais macro mes amis c'est aussi un
président qui a divisé qui a
profondément divisé les français
un président qui au final a abîmé la
france et qui a laissé michel le disait
s'installer depuis maintenant près de
six mois
la violence dans la rue qui a fracturé
la france avec ces images terrifiantes
que nous subissons chaque semaine deux
policiers agressés de commerces pillés
de magasins vandalisés mes amis le 26
mai prochain
nous devons envoyer un préavis très
clair le premier préavis électorale pour
signifier à monsieur macron que la fin
de son bail va approcher
mais nous devons aussi mais nous devrons
aussi mes chers compagnons aller pour
certains ce mot nous parle
nous devrons aussi offrir une vraie
espérance aux français qui d'autre
laurent que les républicains pourraient
incarner cette alternance responsable et
crédible
sûrement pas les extrêmes ils se sont
discrédités et ils ont marqué leur
incompétence pour moi dans cette
campagne européenne
il n'y a qu'un seul chemin et il n'y a
qu'un seul dessein kin wah doo guider
c'est celui de la france pour nous la
nation française ne sera jamais un objet
d huez arrangé au musée de l'histoire
défendre la france c'est choisir une
europe mieux protégés avec des
frontières établies et sûr
non mes amis le danger pour notre
civilisation
ce n'est pas d'aimer notre nation ce
n'est pas non plus d'aimer sa nation
comme le prétend emmanuel macron le
véritable danger c'est bien la
disparition des nations et la
disparition de l'europe et qui menace
aujourd'hui cette civilisation qui
menacent nos nations si ce n'est cet
islamisme cet extrémisme islamiste que
nous avons le devoir l'exigence
l'impératif catégorique de combattre de
toutes nos forces
oui le meilleur rempart contre la
barbarie islamiste
c'est d'assumer ce que nous sommes l'âme
européenne
ces roms c'est paris c'est la tène la
mort aux pnc l'esprit des cathédrales la
philosophie des lumières le respect de
la femme la liberté de croire ou de ne
pas croire
l'alliance de nos racines chrétiennes
et des lumières est ce que l'âme
européenne va choisir de résister aux
forces qui menacent son existence
nous en doutons en tout cas lorsque l'on
regarde du côté des marcheurs
quand les ministres castaner et l'oiseau
assimile le voile islamique à la voile
est de mère teresa quand marlène scapa
extraordinaire compare les militants de
la manif pour tous à des djihadistes
quand le gouvernement refuse d'expulser
les quatre huiles étrangers radicaliser
qui représente pour nous et on les
connaît une menace grave pour notre
sécurité
alors oui avec les républicains
nous voulons tout simplement que la
france reste la france et nous voulons
que l'europe reste l'europe nous voulons
transmettre et ce mot est beau
françois-xavier es tu là souvent
théorisé nous voulons transmettre à nos
enfants des repères des valeurs un mode
vie notre culture notre langue
bref notre civilisation nous voulons
nous voulons que le drapeau tricolore
celui qui nous émeut celui qui nous
rassemble celui qui nous fédère celui
qui nous rappelle notre histoire le
combat glorieux de ceux qui ont versé
leur sang pour nos libertés
oui nous voulons que ce drapeau
tricolore continue à flotter comme ce
sera bientôt le cas dans toutes les
classes et toutes les écoles de france
grâce à l'amendement que j'ai fait
adopter à l'assemblée nationale
alors oui ensemble nous devons dire à
ceux qui veulent rejoindre notre nation
à ceux qui veulent rejoindre notre
continent que ce n'est pas à la france
pas plus qu'à l'europe de s'adapter à
leur culture d'origine mais que c'est à
eux de s'assimiler à notre culture nous
disons nous disons mes amis dans le même
esprit que ce n'est pas notre pays ce
n'est pas à la france de se soumettre à
l'iss mal à l'islam politique conquérant
et violent mais c'est à l'islam de
respecter les lois de la république
alors mes amis alors mes amis ces
combats essentiels sont devant nous nous
devons préserver l'héritage de ceux qui
nous ont précédés
soyons fidèles au message de ces hommes
et de ces femmes qui ont fait l'histoire
de france soyons fidèle à l'héritage du
général de gaulle de georges pompidou de
valéry giscard d'estaing de jacques
chirac de nicolas sarkozy
et je le dis aussi et je le dis aussi
parce que pour moi c'est une question de
fidélité et de dignité parce qu'il a été
courageux soyons fidèles au beau projet
qu'avait apporté françois fillon en 2017
soyons fidèles pour conclure au message
de philippe seguin lorsqu'ils défendent
est une europe moins naïve avec charles
pasqua
oui oui nous voulons l'europe mais
disait-il nous voulons l'europe debout
parce que ces deux bouts qu'on écrit
l'histoire le 26 mai mes amis nous
allons réécrire
nous allons écrire cette belle page de
l'histoire de france
debout avec vous alors oui
battez vous mobilisez vous fait gagner
avec laurent wauquiez françois-xavier
bellamy
[Applaudissements]